i remember the first time we got on a
start line
and it's just adrenaline blood was
pumping heart rate was racing
being on a sidecar does add the extra
dimension because you've got to work
with the person next to you
having him as my brother in the sidecar
is what it's all about
i'm sam helton i'm andy houghton we're
brothers and we're a competitive sidecar
class team
i started racing probably when i was
about 10.
um i'd been on a bike since four years
old
oh there you go that's a mean look isn't
it i was
maybe 13 in that picture
sam beat me once in the last race that
we had no yeah yeah yeah yeah
still only ever beating me once yeah
won my first championship with the local
club about 11 or 12 years old rode a
bike all the way up through different
championships to i was 24 in 2005 and
that's when i had my accident
i had an accident while i was out
training
i ended up going over the handlebars and
landing flat on my back
shattered my t7 vertebrae
that one moment kind of changed my life
i came out of hospital i know i spent a
couple of years without without doing
much
it's only so long that you can fend off
that desire and that bug to get back on
a bike
we found the sidecar and now i'm out
racing this thing which is fantastic
when i tell people that i race sidecar
they seem to assume that i'm going to be
the one in the passenger side but
that's not the case
i'm on the bike
the guys in the sidecar there's no
sitting there's no sitting at all
they're throwing themselves from left to
right and you've got to be fully
able-bodied
my role on the team is effectively to
turn the bike in to keep it level
to do that it's a case of chucking your
weight from side to side
if andrew wants to go one way and i'm
not on the same wavelength we're not
going that way
most of the time he knows what i'm going
to do as brothers you've probably got
that that relationship a little bit
closer than you would otherwise
that feeling you get when you're out on
the track
for me it's what i live for
you get it banked into a corner and
you've got the bike drifting sideways
i'm out there and no one knows that i'm
in a wheelchair no one knows
you're just one of the guys you're a
sidecar racer you're not a disabled guy
and it's just it's an amazing feeling
you